sur ce journal avec la guerre en Ukraine
et cette confusion ce vendredi autour de
soleda la Russie annonce la prise de la
ville mais ce vendredi après-midi Kiev
démon les combats seraient toujours en
cours on en parle avec vous Antoine
Mariotti bonjour concrètement qu'est-ce
que l'on sait pour l'instant est-ce que
Solidar a été prise ou non par les
Russes il y a énormément d'incertitudes
parce que vous avez plusieurs
déclarations d'un côté comme de l'autre
donc russe et ukrainien puis vous avez
plusieurs déclarations différentes aussi
côté russe avec le groupe Wagner qui
affirme depuis deux jours avoir pris
soledar finalement maintenant c'est
l'armée russe on sait qu'il y a cette
rivalité finalement entre ces
mercenaires de Wagner et qui sont
concrètement Manu Kremlin mais l'armée
russe aussi et les Ukrainiens démente
fortement alors ils disent oui c'est
vrai ça fait des mois qu'il y a des
combats dans cette zone qui est qui sont
d'une extrême intensité ces derniers
jours que la bataille est
particulièrement féroce et sanglante
d'ailleurs on parle d'énormément de
morts même si l'impossible d'en avoir un
bilan précis les Russes affirment que
depuis hier soir donc ils ont récupérer
la ville les Ukrainiens disent non la
nuit a été particulièrement chaude mais
il y a toujours des combats et il faut
pas prendre des petites retraites par ci
par-là de certains immeubles ou des
manœuvres pour une défaite globale ce
n'est pas du tout le cas selon encore
une fois
qui est alors du coup qui accuse
évidemment Moscou de faire la propagande
du bruit informationnel faux pour
reprendre leurs mots donc voilà en tout
cas si jamais c'est le cas d'ores et
déjà ou si c'est le cas dans les heures
ou dans les jours qui viennent ce serait
quand même une première victoire
militaire depuis plusieurs mois pour les
Russes avec on le sait on parle tous les
jours un nombre de revers importants
depuis l'été dernier pour les Russes qui
non seulement eu un mal fou à contenir
leur leur position finalement mais qui
n'arrive de toute façon plus du tout à
avancer après il est intéressant de voir
cette bataille entre Wagner dont je
parlais et l'armée russe parce qu'il est
aussi plus facile finalement de prendre
une petite ville comme soledar qui
faisait à peine 10 12 les habitants
avant le conflit qui était en grande
partie deserté par ses habitants et les
civils qui est en grande partie détruite
aussi c'est bien plus facile que de
prendre darkmouth qui est à une petite
quinzaine de kilomètres au sud et qui
pour le coup est une bataille beaucoup
plus stratégique et une ville plus
importante 80 000 habitants avant le
début de la guerre et donc comme il n'y
arrive pas les Russes c'est peut-être
même si ça peut leur simplifier un peu
la vie on en reparlera plus facile aussi
de prendre une petite ville comme ça
pour symboliquement avoir en fait une
première victoire et si cette première
victoire est côté Wagner évidemment ça
les arrange vis-à-vis de l'armée c'est
pour ça que l'armée c'est aussi de
reprendre le monopole de la
communication merci beaucoup Antoine
Mariotti on vous retrouve un peu plus
tard pour continuer à parler de